Hello各位同学大家好
今天Macro想来跟同学们分享
Gemini Spark的这个自动化的功能
这个自动化的功能可以让我们在24小时里面
都可以去执行一些特定的任务
你可以在左边排成这个地方
设定某个时间点让AI去替你执行任务
你也可以新增技能
让AI在执行任务的时候
可以参考我们的技能来执行
也可以去连接我们的一些应用程式
那今天Macle主要会以公文写作为范例来跟同学们分享
也就是说我要去写一份公文
我希望他能够参考一些写作的技能
来帮我写出比较符合规范的公文
那这里写出来的公文就会真的比较符合公务机关的这一个公文的写作
那今天Macle会先带同学们来建立技能
这个技能会让他去连接我们的Gemini Notebook
然后来帮我们写出这一份公文
那我们刚刚提到的这个Spark的这一个功能
它必须是Pro的用户才能够使用
同学们如果是免费的账号
暂时可能没有办法用Spark这个功能
那Macro今天也会跟大家分享
如果我们今天没有Spark
我们如何在即时通讯这里
也能够写出比较正式的公文
那另外还要跟同学们分享另外一个消息
今年度Google AI针对大专院校的
免费一年的方案又出来了
那同学们如果是大专院校
就是你有EDU的账号的话
你都可以来尝试的申请看看
不过今年度的这个额度有点缩水
你如果是大学生符合资格
你只能领到Plus的这个方案
能够领到一整年免费
那如果你符合这个资格
你想要用到Pro的方案的话
你可能每个月要付100多块
同学如果有兴趣的话
你也可以搜索Google AI2026大学生免费方案
就有很多教学告诉你如何去领取
这一个免费的Google AI
那有符合资格的同学
不要错过今年的机会
好 那我们就回到我们刚刚所提到的
这一个Gemini Spark这一个
我们今天的范例是以公文协作为范例
所以我希望他在帮我写公文的时候
能够参考我的公文协作规范
然后也要参考一些政府采购法
所以我就把这些规范放在
Gemini Notebook底下
那我在这边就有建立了几本笔记本
我建立了一个台湾政府机关公文写作技巧
然后也建立了一本政府采购法的一个
相关的一些规范在里面
那这里我先以这一个公文写作技巧为范例
我们如果要建立这一个公文写作的笔记本的话
只要新建一个笔记本好 那我们新建笔记本之后同学就可以新增来源然如果你的单位里面呢有一些公文写作的规范你就可以把档案给上传上来哦
那如果没有的话也没有关系
我们就直接呢在网路上搜索
台湾地区政府机关公文写作指南与用语这里
那Macro因为现在在录影
所以呢我就使用快速搜索
那同学们时间比较多的话
你就用深度搜索
可以找到比较多的来源
那快速搜索呢一次可能10个
深度搜索大概二三十个不一定
好 那我们搜索就按这个箭头
那等他找到资料之后呢
我们就可以筛选
然后没有问题的资料
我们就把它汇入进来
那汇入进来也就会有一本
这一个跟公文写作相关的笔记本
好 那快速搜索
很快就找到这些相关的资料了
我们可以点这一个查看
然后看看里面的资料呢
是不是符合我们想要的
你也可以点这个箭头啊
连部去看一下里面的这些资讯呢
是不是有符合你要的
会不会资料太久之类的
像这个96年会不会太久了
好 那我们假设这些资料都是我们要的
我们就可以点贿赂
如果你的单位里面有写作的这一个档案的话
你贿赂进来可能比较适合
那我现在因为没有
所以我就去网路上找
好 那这些资料贿赂进来之后呢
如果我们这里还有一些备注啊
我们就可以在右边点这个新增记事
那点了新增记事之后呢
比如说我这边还有一些我指定的这一些
可能层级的这些编号的方式
我就把它备注过来
那备注过来之后呢
我就给它一个这个标题
把它放在这儿
好 那我们这边的补充资料放进来之后呢
你像我们等一下在写公文的时候
也能够参考到这些资料的话
你就得把它转换为来源
让它到左边这边来
那我们刚刚看到下面有一个这个粉色
这个代表说这个资料呢
没有办法汇入进来
所以我们就可以点这个点点点
然后把它移除
好
移除之后呢
我们再点这个新增来源
你就可以看到啊
这本笔记本呢
里面可以放300个来源
那我现在已经用掉10个了
那同学如果是免费的账号
你最多就是50个来源
好
那这本笔记本建立好了之后呢
我们就把它放着
然后同学们就再新建一个笔记本
相同的做法
然后就是找政府采购法
好
那我们现在已经有两本笔记本了
那我这边其实已经好多本了
所以我这本先删除哦
好
那我们笔记本建立好了
之后我们就回到我们的 Gemini Spark 这里
然后第一个先到这个连结的应用程式
然后在Google的Workspace这个地方
你要启用连结
就是让它可以连结到Google文件
或Google的云端硬碟
然后下面这个 Gemini Notebook
也把它打开来
就是它可以
这个技能可以连接到
我们刚刚所新增的这个笔记本好 打开来之后我们就到技能这里那进来之后你可以以手动建立比如说你有想法了你名称要取什么说明然后这个技能里面要执行什么样的动作
你就可以自己写
那如果你不知道该怎么写的话呢
我们就可以呢
透过Gemini来建立
那透过Gemini来建立呢
就简单了
我们就可以直接跟他讲说
建立一个公文写作的技能
然后参考我的Gemini Notebook里面的采购
跟公文相关的笔记本资料
依据我的需求来帮我写这个公文
然后必须要符合台湾地区的公文写作规范
好这个是我跟他讲
我要建立的技能的需求
让我们就送出
那送出之后
他就会帮我们把这个技能给建立起来
好所以呢
他有连接到我们的Gemina Notebook了
好我们可以看到呢
技能的名称已经帮我们取好了
然后他有连接到里面的几本笔记本
而且里面可能蛮多本的
所以他就找到这几本笔记本
这里我就跟他讲说参考的笔记本
以这个圈圈开头的这两本笔记本为主
所以他建立好之后
你还是可以请他再微调
好他已经锁定这两本笔记本了
那我们现在技能已经建立好了
所以我们的技能名称就是这一个技能名称
那接着我们就来到左边这个技能
稍微看一下
他已经帮我们建立好这个技能了
好建立好之后
我们要如何来使用呢
我们可以把星星打开来
然后到工作这个地方
点工作进来之后呢
你只要在提示框这里输入一个斜线
你输入斜线之后呢
就可以找到这一个技能
好
那我们找到这个技能之后呢
我们就可以把我们的需求写上来
比如说我们跟他讲说呢
我想要写一个这一个数位工具应用培训研习会
然后我预计要多少钱
我今天要办这一个研讨会
所以我需要讲师费啊
场地布置费啊等等
然后请他帮我写一个千层
好了这我们就送出
所以这里我们就可以看到
他有去连接到我们的German9 Notebook
去看我们的写作规范
同学可能会觉得说
那平常我开启一个German9的聊天视窗
我一样告诉他需求之后
他就能够帮我写文啦
其实这样也是可以
只是没有给他一些参考的资料
可能写出来你要修改的地方会比较多
那有些时候我们在一个聊天室
里面呢
常常在里面写了很多次文之后
他可能会有上下文的干扰
文件的内容也比较容易混淆
那再来就是每一次写出来的公文风格
可能都会有微波的差异
也许格式就不是那么的准确
有时候我们在写文的时候呢
可能会跟采购有一点关系
所以这个时候呢
我们如果给他一些参考的这些依据的话
那写出来的文呢
可能比较能够让我们少改一些内容所以这边他就告诉我们他依据我们的政府财购法跟公文写作的规范然后帮我们写出了这一份公文
然后我们再往下面看
可以看到这里有一个word的档案
我们把它打开来
那打开来之后同学就可以在这边修修改改
比如说你觉得这个可能不适合
你就可以把它改掉
这个公文写出来其实就是一个初稿
同学们还是得修修改改
改成比较符合你单位里面的一些用法
但至少呢里面一些比较该注意的地方
用语的地方呢
我们都不用太去担心说我们写错
这个呢是在SPARK底下呢
我们设定技能连接到Gemini Notebook
来帮我们写公文
那刚好提到呢
如果你是免费的用户
你可能没有SPARK可以使用
那怎么办呢
没有关系
我们就用Gemini来帮我们写作
那这里我先把这里都关掉
我们回来Gemini
即时通讯这里
回来之后呢
你一样是这个Gemini Notebook
你还是要把这几本笔记本都建好
那建好之后我们在写公文的时候
我们就可以点这个加号
然后到更多找到我们的No Books这里
然后点进来之后
你就可以找到你的这两本笔记本
两个都把它打勾起来
然后按新增
按了新增之后呢
你再把你刚刚写公文的需求给贴上来
好然后下面这个地方的加号
我们就可以选择我们要用Canvas
好然后松出
其实这样子也蛮方便
就我们只要点加号进来之后呢
然后去找到我们的这两本笔记本
再把需求写上来
其他也是可以帮我们写出公文
只是有时候这个排版就不是排得太好
你可能就是要这样子在这里直接进行分段
那刚刚我测试的这一个Spark
写出来的这一个排版
我感觉是比较好一点
好 那这里有一个问题
就是同学们如果下一次又要写公文的时候
如果你下次在下面这个地方
再把你的需求打上来
然后按松出
比较有可能会上下文干扰
比如说你下面再写一个公文
可能上面的一些内容就影响到下面
那这里比较建议大家就是建立一个GEM
可是GEM它其实在可能10月份左右
就会停止资源这个功能
所以以后的GEM可能会消失
那目前还不确定
是有听说会消失
可能未来都会跑到这个Spark底下的技能
就是Skills的方式
那可能也只会提供给Pro的用户来使用
今天跟同学们分享
就会买链接笔记本的用法
同学们如果有兴趣的话
都可以尝试看看
那今天的影片就跟同学们分享到这里
那我们下部影片见
拜拜